wearetakingyourcallsat6­17­8­30,47­50.let's
gonexttoourcollar,fromthe626areacode,who'scallingtoday,from626aDavidforsomeConn.
butIloveyourshow,thankyou.
Solook,thedemocraticestablishmentwillstopatnothingtomakesurethatBertieSandersisnot
phenomena,disgustingtowatch.Andit'sbigreportedthateventhoughbracesnotofficially
endorsingabuthecalledPODGEtodropoutandendorsetobin.Hemayhaveevencalledthator
totothesamething.Whereisiteither?Whereisthatbeingreported?
Iheardfromarebelageto...
Okay,Idon'tknowifheisina...ButIsee,listento,here'sthething,here'sthething,you're
absolutelyright,andThisishowpoliticsworks,thisisnotsuperdelegates,thisistheDNC.
03/06/20 Page8of17
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­06­commercialfree
realizing,"Heyweprobablyhaveacoalitionhere.Bernieprobablyhassomesealing.Thepundits
wereverywrongaboutwhatthatceilingwastheysaiditwas15­20.IfIbringoutthe30okay,but
thisishowpoliticsworks,thisisthegame.Theyplayedit,andtheyarewinninganditsucks.And
theprogressivemovementneedstorealizethatwhenwetalkaboutunilateraldisarmamentwedon't
takepackmoney,andifwedon'tdothis,andwedon'tdothatinBubba,blah,blah,butatacertain
point,there'salineatwhich...Well,thenyou'regonnaloseandthatisgoingtoprohibityoufrom
thengettingintoapositiontomakethechangethatyouwanttheIdobelievethatwe,progressives,
needtotakealessonfromthisthough,whichisaveryspecificone,whichiswe'reanonlinemedia.
AlotofpeoplewhowatchtheshowloveBernie.AlotofpeoplewhofollowmeonTwitterlove
burningalotofpeopleonoursubredditloveBernie.
ThisisnotrepresentativeoftheDemocraticPartyatlargeit'sjustnotright,becausewhenyou
combinetherealitiesinalotofthesedifferentstates,yourealizealotofpeoplejustdidn'twanna
vote.ForBernie,that'sit,yes,ofcourse,theDNCorchestratedthetimingofthis.There'snodoubt,
ifithadbeenatwo­candidateracefromthebeginningwemighthavehaddifferentresultsallalong
butwealsoshouldn'tassumethatifyoujustexplainBernie'spositionstopeople,everyonewill
wannavoteforhim.There'speoplewhojustdon'twannavoteforBernieandintheeulogy,ifthere
isonewhichwe'renotdoingrightnow,we'llhavetotalkaboutthewayBernie'scampaignwas
framed.democraticsocialismwillhavetotalkaboutallofthesedifferentthingsanddiscussthe
effecttheyhad.Butyeah,thisisjustthereality.Andprogressiveswe,progressives,havetofaceit.
SoIguessmyquestionis,whatdoyouthink?Okay,sotheDemocratsnominateJobyinJoliet,ina
lastleg,'causehe'sgrip.
Whatdoyouthinkoftheprogressives,theprogressivesleavingjustcompletelyabandoningthe
DemocraticPartyandcreatingtheirownpartygoodestateatasa,thattheocraticparty.Itcould
happen,butIwannathrowsomethingelseout.
Aboutamonthandahalfago,Igaveoutthefourwaysthatthiscouldgothefourwaysthatcould
go,orBernienominatedandbecomesPresident,BernienominatedandlosestoTrumpbyeand
nominatedandbecomesPresident,bydenominatedandlosestoTrump.AndwhenIdidthatstory,I
said,Ifyoutakeeverythingintoconsideration,ifyoutaketheSenatebalanceintoconsiderationif
youtakeallthesedifferentthingslong­term,thebestoutcomefortheprogressivemovementmight
bethatbinisnominatedandloses.Now,Iwon'tredotheanalysisnowbecausesomanyofmy
audiencemembershavealreadyheardit.It'salong­termplanandit'sdifficultbutitmaynotbethe
worstthingfortheProgressiveMovementandIexplainwhyinthatsegment.
Yeah,Agrawal,thankyoudo,butIappreciateyouansweringmycall.Alright,mypleasure,thank
yousomuchforcallingin.